so what makes disease such a powerful
insult well I'm not an animal just as
you know but when I wrote a book about
bio hacking and sensory perception I
learned a lot about how finely-tuned
your brain is for danger and one of your
biggest defences against biological
danger or which is germs is discussed
right and so disgust is at least partly
learned and that you have to learn
something about what it is to avoid if
you've ever watched a baby pick up a
band-aid you know that those protocols
are not all hardwired right so we're
cute about what should it's that's your
brain for analogy not in actual science
so we're we're cute about what should
disgust us in a couple of ways so one is
that it's learned through your sense of
smell and taste but basically by things
that you've had bad experiences with so
if you've had a run-in with an
unfortunate shrimp then you're gonna be
off shrimp for a while right um we're
all so unnerved by a face that doesn't
look like a face so uh or doesn't look
entirely like a face so a healthy face
should be symmetrical and proportional
and when it's not that's an indicator to
us either of a disease or it's an
indicator that's that something is dead
that it's rotting right and either way
your brain goes oh my god there's a
pathogen whatever got him could get me
so I need to get away this is the origin
of the uncanny valley which you have
probably all heard of before the idea
that we like images of human faces that
are photorealistic so kind of the curve
goes up as things get more humanoid and
then it drops when things get close to
photorealistic but not quite and then
they they go up again when they're
totally realistic so this is not the
original drawing of the uncanny valley
by Masahiro mori this is a reworking
that I found on Wikimedia Commons by a
guy or a lady I know only as s Murray
and Chester
but whoever this person is is a genius
because they've amended the original to
add corpse which is germane to our point
and zombie
right there at the low point so finally
the other way we learn what to avoid is
by looking at other people's reactions
so there is a universally recognized
disgust face that kind of we
automatically do when we eat something
that's spoiled or the or bitter
so Rachel Hirst who's a researcher on
that your sense of smell wrote a book
called that's disgusting that is all
about this and she describes that face
this way
she said we close our body especially
our face off from invasion which is why
your upper lip retracts your nose
scrunches up and your eye is squint and
if it's really bad you might coffee you
might spit you would stick out your
tongue you might even throw up you're
trying to expel the bad thing from your
body and when you see somebody doing
this you know to avoid whatever it is
that they just ate or touched and so
when physical wretchedness stands in for
moral wretchedness it triggers the same
feeling which is discussed in the same
reaction which is avoidance and the
facial cues we use for social rejection
or something that disgusts us morally
are the same you squint your face you
sneer you you stick out your tongue you
make fake gagging motions and all of
these are signals of social contempt and
of a person or a behavior that we should
avoid
and so insults serve this purpose to
this signal contempt and they assert
your own social status while they
diminish somebody else's
[Music]